lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
presentar una introducción o intuición
para el término de flujo en general y
después ver cómo se aplica a la idea del
flujo magnético
en general cuando las personas hablan de
flujo y esa es la forma que a mí se me
hace más fácil de explicarlo se refieren
a que tanto de algo está pasando a
través de una superficie en un tiempo
dado si ustedes se imaginan que aquí
estoy definiendo un volumen de aire y
digamos que el aire está más denso aquí
abajo hay más moléculas de aire hay más
moléculas aquí
de lo que hay aquí arriba que esto en
general es lo que ocurre normalmente
la cantidad o la densidad de aire va a
disminuir conforme aumentemos nuestra
altitud y bueno aquí hay partículas
intermedias que pues bueno van a hacer
un poco más densas que las de hasta
arriba pero no tan densas como las de
hasta abajo y no voy a dibujar todas las
partículas de aire que pueda haber aquí
pero al menos serán ustedes una idea de
que aquí abajo hay muchas moléculas de
aire aquí por el medio pues va a menos y
hasta aquí arriba hay pocas y también
vamos a decir que estas moléculas de
aire se están moviendo vamos a dibujar
algunos vectores de velocidad por
ejemplo puede ser que aquí una molécula
se esté moviendo hacia acá aquí hay otra
que se está moviendo así están digamos
que a una velocidad intermedia pero
digamos que conforme nos estamos
moviendo más hacia esta dirección el
aire se está volviendo más rápido tiene
más velocidad
por lo que sus vectores de velocidad van
a ser más grandes vemos que en general y
vemos que todo el aire se está moviendo
en una dirección general hacia acá como
lo estoy dibujando
puedo dibujar más vectores velocidad por
acá pero se cumpla la tendencia de que a
la izquierda el aire se mueve con menor
velocidad y a la derecha se mueve con
mayor velocidad
'estoy muestreando algunos vectores
velocidad ahora hablemos del flujo
cuando hablamos del flujo en general
tenemos que pensar en una superficie
imaginemos que vamos a tener una red más
o menos por acá
y el flujo va a ser qué cantidad de aire
va a estar atravesando esta red durante
cierta cantidad de tiempo podemos decir
cuántas moléculas están viajando no sé a
lo mejor cada segundo por lo que esto va
a tener un flujo asociado al menos en
relación con el aire pero qué pasaría si
tomáramos esta red que es una red
teórica ya que no nos va a impedir el
paso del aire a través de ella solamente
nos ayuda a visualizar la superficie qué
pasaría si yo no hubiera esta red un
poquito más hacia la derecha en donde
hay una mayor velocidad en el aire y
siguen habiendo más partículas porque
estamos aquí abajo bueno pues ahora aquí
el flujo va a aumentar
un mayor flujo
mayor flujo porque aumentó el flujo
bueno aquí la densidad es la misma pero
las moléculas de aire se están moviendo
a mayor velocidad por lo que durante el
mismo lapso de tiempo vamos a tener más
cosas que van a estar pasando a través
de esta red oa través de esta superficie
y qué pasaría si yo tomara esta red pero
la colocó a una altura mayor
la velocidad de estas moléculas va a ser
la misma y van a ir en la misma
dirección pero aquí arriba tengo menos
moléculas de aire en comparación de lo
que tenía aquí abajo por lo que vamos a
tener menos moléculas que estén pasando
a través de esta superficie durante
cierta cantidad de tiempo así que esta
va a tener un menor flujo y le estoy
comparando con nuestra primera red menor
y qué tal si tomáramos la misma red pero
en lugar de hacer que el aire pase de
manera perpendicular a la superficie es
decir su orientación fuera igual que el
movimiento del aire ahora tendríamos la
misma red pero estaría en esta posición
más o menos aunque no luce igual que
ésta pero imaginemos que es la misma red
bueno ahora cuanto aire estaría pasando
a través de esta red en cierta cantidad
de tiempo pues ahora nada del aire
estaría pasando por esta superficie ya
que el aire es paralelo a esta
superficie no la va a atravesar como que
la va a rozar nada más en este caso
vamos a tener cero flujo no va a haber
flujo porque todas las moléculas de aire
van a pasar de manera paralela a esta
reja ninguna la va a atravesar ahora
imaginemos que esta red que no impide el
paso del aire podemos estirar la un poco
digamos que podemos estirarla hacia acá
hacia arriba
es una red más grande
más o menos así ahora esto va a tener un
mayor flujo ya que es una superficie más
grande y más cantidad de moléculas van a
poder atravesar toda esta superficie así
que para esta superficie más grande
vamos a tener un mayor flujo porque hay
más partículas de aire que pueden pasar
a través de ella y no olviden que esto
siempre ocurre en cierta unidad de
tiempo entonces van a pasar más
partículas de aire en una unidad de
tiempo dado así que cuando vemos cuánto
de algo puede atravesar una superficie
en cierto tiempo hablamos del concepto
general de flujo entonces cuando vemos
cuánto de algo pasa a través de una
superficie en cierta cantidad de tiempo
en el sentido tradicional del flujo va a
depender bueno en este ejemplo de la
densidad de la sustancia va a depender
también de su velocidad tanto de la
magnitud de la velocidad como de su
dirección vemos que si orientamos la
superficie de otra manera
sea paralela a la velocidad y que no sea
normal o perpendicular a esta velocidad
nuestra superficie pues veremos que va a
disminuir nuestro flujo y podemos tener
cosas intermedias digamos que tenemos
nuestra red original pero la vamos a
colocar de manera que no se encuentra
totalmente perpendicular al vector
velocidad de mis partículas pero tampoco
se encuentra paralelo a ellos el flujo
que pase por acá va a ser intermedio
entre el flujo que tenemos acá nuestro
flujo original y este que pusimos de
ejemplo aquí vamos a tener partículas de
aire que estén pasando a través de esta
red pero van a tener un ángulo con
respecto a la superficie diferente no
será un ángulo de 90 grados como en este
ejemplo de aquí más adelante vamos a
explorar esto con más detalle cuando
veamos más el aspecto matemático cuando
veamos a que el componente de estos
vectores velocidad
o sea perpendicular a la superficie y de
esta manera eventualmente podremos
calcular el flujo pero por el momento
solamente noten que el flujo de aquí va
a ser un flujo intermedio entre este que
todo es perpendicular a su superficie y
este otro que la red está paralela al
movimiento de la velocidad y que ninguna
molécula de aire va a atravesar su
superficie bueno esta es la definición o
la intuición que para mí es la más
básica o general del flujo ahora a qué
nos referimos con el flujo magnético de
igual manera que con nuestro concepto
original vamos a estar trabajando con
cuanto de algo va a estar pasando a
través de una superficie pero en lugar
de estar pensando en partículas de aire
o partículas de agua o cosas por el
estilo vamos a pensar en el campo
magnético
dibujar una superficie aquí tengo una
barra magnética este es el lado norte
este es el lado sur
aquí tenemos nuestras líneas de campo y
aquí he dibujado algunos de los vectores
de campo magnético y digamos que tenemos
una superficie
más o menos así
esta superficie cuando hablamos del
flujo magnético no nos referimos a cosas
tangibles que estén pasando a través de
la superficie como lo vimos en este
ejemplo del concepto más tradicional de
flujo donde tenemos partículas de algo
que estaban pasando a través de la
superficie es un concepto similar pero
en este caso aquí nos interesa el
componente del campo magnético o la
densidad del campo magnético que es
normal a esta superficie digamos que
esto ya tiene cierto flujo dado y lo
llamamos fi que es la forma de definir o
la letra para definir el flujo de un
campo magnético y está basado en la
fuerza del campo magnético en especial
el componente del flujo magnético que es
normal a esta superficie los rectores
que son perpendiculares a esta
superficie
así que esto tendrá cierto flujo
magnético pero si yo tomara la misma
superficie pero la pusiera paralela
al movimiento del campo magnético
o paralelo a los vectores del campo
magnético si estos vectores fueran
paralelos y no normales con respecto a
esta superficie
entonces ya no tendríamos flujo
magnético aquí así que aquí tendríamos
casi cercano a cero flujo magnético casi
no tendríamos
magnético
y si yo tomara de nuevo esta superficie
y en lugar de ponerla a que la alejará
digamos que la dibujo hasta por acá
donde ya hay muy pocos vectores del
campo magnético o digamos que nuestro
campo magnético aquí ya es muy débil
hay poquitos aquí
el flujo también va a disminuir así que
hay muchas propiedades similares de lo
que habíamos visto en la definición
tradicional con nuestro flujo magnético
pero en lugar de hablar de la velocidad
de las partículas de aire o los vectores
velocidad de las partículas de aire y
cómo se relacionan estos con la
superficie aquí vamos a hablar de los
vectores del campo magnético y como esos
se relacionan con la superficie pero la
analogía entre estos dos sigue siendo la
misma si son perpendiculares tendremos
un mayor flujo si van en la misma
dirección
podríamos tener cero o muy muy poquito
flujo magnético si tenemos un campo
magnético débil por acá el flujo también
va a ser más pequeño si tenemos un campo
magnético fuerte que sea análogo a lo
que teníamos aquí mayor densidad o mayor
velocidad que nos causa un flujo mayor
comparado con tener una menor densidad o
una menor velocidad
a un flujo menor y también podemos hacer
más grande el área de nuestro flujo de
manera que tengamos una mayor superficie
aquí por lo que el flujo que pasa a
través de esta superficie va a ser mayor
que el que pasa en esta superficie
digamos que esta superficie es parecida
a esta superficie de aquí y el campo
magnético es simétrico en ambos lados el
flujo en esta superficie sería el mismo
o es el mismo que el flujo de esta
superficie de acá pero como estiramos
esto para tener una mayor superficie
tenemos una mayor cantidad del campo
magnético que es normal a esta
superficie yo espero que con esto
ustedes ya tengan al menos una idea
general de lo que es el flujo magnético
y como éste se relaciona con digamos que
el flujo con el que estamos más
familiarizados